hi there steve kaufman
i am continuing of course with my korean
challenge but i want to today i want to
talk about how great it is to be alive
at this time in history
because we hear all the doom and gloom
save the planet save the planet from
what the planet is in no danger the only
thing that can happen is that the
ecosystem that we enjoy
might be changed for a variety of
reasons including what we're doing to it
and that it become might become it'll
become more favorable for certain
ecosystems or certain organisms and it
might become less favorable for humans
so we bought it we got to be careful but
it's the human
centered uh you know convenience of the
planet that will be affected not the
planet okay
so uh obviously we have to be careful
there and it's very encouraging to see
the kind of uh
progress that we're making in terms of
uh more pollution-free
uh you know uh ways of generating energy
and so forth and so on so i'm a great
believer in in things positive and and i
like globalization i like the fact that
through the uh you know the fact that we
can access i can
you know this morning i want to make an
omelette i look up uh i had some spinach
spinach omelette look it up in french i
get a french recipe for spinach omelette
i go and make the spinach omelet reading
my korean stuff uh i you know in the car
i subscribe to a bunch of podcasts and
and they'll kind of click through to the
next one the next the next one so i'll
be listening to our korean podcast
followed by a polish podcast followed by
ukrainian podcast connected to the world
what a great way to be you know and
and because we are connected to the
world and the fact that people in other
countries are making things that come to
my country that they supply me with
things people elsewhere are making
things you know even my ipad it's
designed by someone in the u.s who
probably was an immigrant from
india or something and then parts are
manufactured in china or vietnam and
they come here and i'm able to use it
and it's quite affordable i mean that's
wonderful yes some people's jobs have
been affected
but
you know if we always try and stay with
the existing sort of employment pattern
we would never have moved forward from
you know child labor
very labor-intensive methods 90 of the
people on the farm everything that
prevailed 150 years ago so there will be
these periods and we have to adjust we
have to invest in education maybe we
need a guaranteed income maybe we need
to accept the fact that we're going to
work less i don't know i'm not in a
position to predict what these things
are going to be i'm just saying that in
terms of my prejudice i like a
globalized world i like the fact that
people in other poorer countries are
able to export products to here of
course there has to be fair trade in
both directions and
initially those countries with lower
wages are going to benefit more
than we are although we benefit as
consumers but the fact now that people
in japan and in china and in india have
greater incomes are better educated they
will also be
doing research and contributing to the
development of new technology new
processes that are going to make the
world a better place so i am a great
optimist
and
uh i just wanted to say that that
because you hear so much doom and gloom
and i think in terms of life inspect
expectancy number of people on the
planet number of people who live in
misery
the sort of uh disposable income that we
have today
we're better off than we ever were
uh
lots of stuff we can do better we can
eat more healthy for example
we can be more conscious of the impact
of what we're doing on the environment
and we are heading in that direction i
think the worst is these people have
this
unrealistically
idealized
vision of what we should be and because
we're not that therefore everything is
bad no that's not true yeah politicians
you know constantly
looking for you know favors and giving
favors that's what it's always been it's
always been everywhere always not gonna
change
uh we're never gonna have a hundred
percent honest politicians but we need
politicians um
so i think the pursuit of perfection
leads to more evil than anything else i
think we have to try little by little
in those things that we can influence
try to make the world a better place
without screaming about how awful and
terrible things are because they aren't
i think they're pretty good
and
people are going to criticize me again
and i'm happy to discuss this subject
and i can give you more reasons why i
think we live in the best possible time
in history anyway thanks for listening
bye for now